I guess the most pressing question what
is the best dumplings you've ever had I
mean it's just the thing that I grew up
eating cuz she would make them so often
for me and with this specific kind of
definitely she'd make would be like pork
and cabbage and it'd be like Beijing
style like boiled dumplings and
sometimes if she's not like not feeling
too tired she'll like make the wrapper
you know by hand but if she's feeling
too tired she like buy premade wrappers
and then she like adjusts the recipe
over the years and then now she adds a
little bit of maple syrup yes I know
weird into the pork filling because you
know it adds that like sweetness hmm
they live in Canada a little bit of
maples here I know I know is it better
with the maple syrup a lot up there I
mean it's like you know adding like a
little bit of sugar to like meat before
you cook it I think it brings out some
of the flavor I honestly can't really
taste it oh I have to say ditto and I
well I had the fortunate opportunity to
get to eat Domi's mom's dumplings as you
may know she came in gave classes to the
crew on how to make dumplings so we all
got to I mean she literally was our muse
so she came so that we can learn but she
also came so that we could study her
techniques and take pictures and video
how she rolls the dough and a lot of
those shots in the film are really taken
from how do me Tony's mom does it and I
got to reap the benefits starting from
the beginning what was sort of the
initial kernel of an idea for for Bao oh
um I guess I I came up with the idea
over four years ago and I really just
wanted to create like a modern-day fairy
tale akin to the little gingerbread man
but with a Chinese spin on it and I just
started drawing and drawing
and this sound I doodled this drawing of
this mother like nuzzling her little
baby dumpling boy to death and I think
that was the first image and I kind of
built the story from there kind of
infusing kind of my own experience you
know being that overprotective coddled
little dumpling - my mom and dad and it
kind of just formed into this story but
I really just wanted to yeah just to do
this like magical food fairytale with
their really like shocking ending how
much of the concept change from those
sort of initial thoughts well it didn't
actually like the core of it didn't
change that much at all when I pitched
it to Pixar like the the core story
beats were still pretty much the same
like it always started off with an
empty-nester you know mom you know
really lonely one day one of her
dumplings comes to life she adopts it
goes through this crazy life journey
with it it tries to leave her and she
ends up eating it and we reveal that it
was all a metaphor for her relationship
with her real son and that was always
the same it was just the little details
that changed like how much do we reveal
or like kind of hint at the beginning
that you know all of this is kind of a
dream or like magical and then the
details of how the mom character and the
dumpling character grow closer together
like the little activities that they
would do together or what are the things
that make them you know split apart like
what are those little specific details
and then the thing that I changed the
most I kept iterating on the most and
the story was the reveal after she eats
the dumpling that it was all a metaphor
for her real son and how to reveal that
to the audience I played around with
different scenarios like I had the mom
character like collapse and pass out and
wake up in the hospital in one version
and that's where the real son comes in
but I was confusing to some people that
we showed it to because they're like why
is she in the hospital is she pregnant
was that guy the doorway a doctor what's
going on so it just took a lot of
iteration just to get it to a place
where we wanted it to feel kind of
ambiguous like what the truth was but we
still wanted it to feel like an
emotional reunion between the mother and
the son what is the process of getting
your shorts were selected are there
other shorts since whatever competition
at Pixar what is that process for
production for choosing it
ah so for me I I kind of was in this
American Idol style like audition
process at Pixar cuz they asked like
anybody in the studio if they had ideas
for the next short film to pitch three
ideas to a panel of judges so I signed
up and I was one of like 50
I think people pitching that day so I
worked really hard for the next couple
of weeks and I did drawings of each of
my three ideas put them up on boards and
I'm like we I wheeled it in to this room
and it you know they were all sitting
there like directors executives
producers we're just sitting there in a
row I was in the front you know and then
I like went through each of my ideas and
I went through multiple rounds you know
because there's like elimination round
oh yeah until finally
bowel was chosen was greenlit as the
next official Pixar theatrical short and
I was in 2015
you